during my career i've worked in some of
the world's best restaurants where every
meal is a special occasion but this type
of food isn't that practical at home
with my ultimate food for special
occasions i'll be showing you some
stunning dishes guaranteed to knock the
socks off anyone but crucially these
dishes are still really easy to pull off
first up one of my family's favorite
breakfast treats sumptuous eggs benedict
with crispy parma ham
followed by a dish fit to take center
stage at any special occasion lunch
luscious grilled lobster served with
bloody mary linguine the smell of that
chili and garlic potter is extraordinary
and jack and i cook up the ultimate
unforgettable dinner for a ramsay clan
get together it doesn't get more
memorable than this nice
a superb rare fillet of beef with salsa
veldi and baked new potatoes with an
indulgent twist
and for dessert an amazing chocolate and
pistachio semi-freddo
these are my ultimate recipes for a
special occasion breakfast lunch and
dinner
kicking things off with a beautiful
breakfast of eggs benedict with crispy
parmesan
the secret behind a great eggs benedict
is in the hollandaise so get your pan on
because i'm going to cook our
hollandaise over a rolling boil with a
glass bowl
butter just put it on to melt three egg
yolks
separated from the white
tarragon vinegar pop that into the eggs
if you can't get tarragon vinegar any
white wine vinegar will do just as long
as you've got that acidity in there give
some bite to the hollandaise put your
bowl
over the rolling water
and just start whisking
if the eggs had direct contact with the
gas
hollandaise will become scrambled egg
once you've got that nice creamy texture
a nice thick savion start adding your
butter
nice and slowly
a couple of tablespoons of butter in
and give that a really nice mix
if you don't whisk it enough the egg
yolks don't take the butter it causes it
to split
with more butter
using a big balloon whisk like this one
makes it easier to incorporate air and
helps prevent your mixture from
separating
all the butter in and the best way to
keep hollandaise nice and warm is just
leave it to sit over that nice warm
water bath and it just keeps at a really
nice room temperature
a nice pinch of salt
fresh pepper and then fresh lemon juice
that just really makes it vibrant
exciting
i want it's like a sort of thick custard
i just want it to coat the back of the
spoon so it's like you're
giving the a nice glossy texture to your
beautiful poached egg now as the base
for the eggs benedict you cannot beat
english muffins but the ham
i'm gonna change i'm gonna use the most
amazing parma ham get your pan nice and
hot
into the
pan like posh rashes are bacon
beautiful
[Music]
parlor ham fried nice and crisp like
that is incredible beautiful in salads
fantastic for eggs benedict
[Music]
now keep that pan nice and hot
i want all that flavor from the parma
ham left in there
and rather than toast my muffins i want
to put the muffins into the pan i'm
sucking up all that wonderful flavor
from that crispy parmesan
make sure your muffins are toasted
nicely this will prevent them going
soggy later
look at that
nice and crisp
now water on to boil for the eggs nicely
seasoned really important and then just
a little splash
of vinegar in the water that helps to
set the egg white the minute you crack
it in
while the water heats up in the pan
there's time to get organized
lay a nice slice of ham on the base
now water's brought up to the ball turn
it down and then spin your water around
like a little whirlpool
then get a little cup so you just drop
the cup in
and look what happens to the egg
gets caught up in the turbulence of the
water
the secret is not the ball the water
rapidly because the strength of the ball
can literally explode your egg as they
start to move the way up to the top of
the water that's a indication that
they're cooked
take off any excess little bits of egg
white
and then out onto a piece of tissue
paper
that just drains off excess water that
stops your muffin from getting really
soggy but look they're like little
beautiful mozzarella balls give them a
little season
lift them on to your crispy parmesan
useful
now get a nice spoon of your hollandaise
glaze over
try and do it in one glazing over the
whole egg
[Applause]
when i tell jack holly and megan and
matilda that we're cooking eggs benedict
for breakfast they bolt down the stairs
and let's be honest who wouldn't run
to sit in front of those
[Music]
a special occasion breakfast that would
make anyone feel spoiled
eggs benedict with crispy parmesan
beauties
[Music]
the key ingredients for my ultimate
special occasion lunch and dinner aren't
cheap
to make sure you get the best value when
you go out shopping here's a closer look
at them
first up for lunch i'll be using one of
the world's ultimate luxury foods
lobsters not cheap but they're sure to
impress
they can be bought live when they're
usually a greeny brown or blue color or
cooked with their more familiar red hue
lobsters can grow to almost five kilo
but the smaller the specimen the more
tender it will be i think three quarters
of a kilo is a good size to go for
if you save the shell it will make an
excellent stock bisque or lobster sauce
[Music]
next the truffle ounce for ounce they're
one of the most expensive foods in the
world rich and earthy in flavor the
price of these subterranean delicacies
is determined by the type shape and size
the good news is a little of these odd
looking fungi will go a long long way
i'll be using shavings of black truffle
to raise some baked potatoes from the
ordinary to the extraordinary
next sensational beef fillet prized for
its melt in the mouth tenderness this
quick to cook lean cut comes from the
loin of the animal running along either
side of the backbone
look for dry aged fillet as the beef
hangs natural enzymes break down the
tissue making it even more succulent and
flavoursome
dry hb philips will be joining my pimped
up truffle potatoes in my superb special
occasion dinner
i don't think home cooking should ever
be difficult even when you're putting
together food for special occasions one
of the key secrets to getting the wow
factor into your food is to buy great
ingredients and let them do the talking
for my ultimate special occasion lunch
i've got some stunning and i mean
stunning lobsters
and i'll be cooking them very simply
with chilli and garlic butter serving
them with bloody mary linguine
[Music]
i'm going to start with the pasta sauce
i love the indulgence in this dish
if i was doing this for the kids i'd
scrap the vodka and just do like a
virgin
[Music]
it's
mary
bit of a grown-ups dish
now pan nice and hot splash of olive oil
onions in
seasoning touch of salt and pepper
garlic
be nice and generous with your garlic
it's not just your average tomato sauce
it's a royal stunning tomato sauce
you're in for a big treat
season your onions and garlic the
tabasco
that'll give that really nice lift
little pinch of celery salt
spice that up with worcester sauce
it instantly colors the tomatoes goes
brilliantly well with a celery salt
tabasco and that nice caramelized garlic
a little light sprinkling of sugar all
the worcester sauce
has reduced down we've got this nice
sweet spicy sticky garlicky
onion base
glaze with a couple of spoons of vodka
in
chopped tomatoes in
little touch of water
look at the color oh that sauce
check the seasoning
that's delicious bring that up to the
boil and cook it out six to eight
minutes reduce it down slowly turn down
the gas let that simmer
with my sauce simmering i can move on to
a delicious breadcrumb topping to dress
my linguini
i'll fry off my breadcrumbs get them
nice and crispy but don't put too much
oil in there otherwise the bread will
just absorb it they become greasy
beautifully season them
and they go really nice and golden brown
30 seconds before they come out flat
leaf parsley roll that through
your breadcrumbs
and that is going to finish the linguini
on top
you can hear how crisp they are
before i cook the linguini i'm going to
make the chili butter that will flavour
my lobster
get your chili and slice it i want to
take advantage of all those seeds
chili in a touch of salt
a nice clove of garlic
and get some parsley
[Music]
start breaking that down but i'm looking
for a lovely garlic chili paste exactly
like that
now don't overdo it with the butter
herb butters are a great way to flavor
fish and meat they can be used as a
stuffing in dishes like chicken kiev or
added towards the end of a dish as a
delicious glaze
lobsters
they're already cooked so
firmly place the lobster flat on your
board there's a little crisscross here
line there and a line going across
put the point of the knife in and just
push through
the head
turn the lobster around
cut through the lobster
snap the legs off
snap the claws off just get the back of
your knife
crack them
spread that beautiful butter on
go into the heads as well
and then the claws take off bits of the
shell
and get little bits of butter in there
this can be done way in advance for me
the longer that chili butter sits on top
of that lobster the better the flavor
especially when they hit the grill
while my lobster firms up in the fridge
i can finish cooking my linguine
water
brought up to the boil
seasoned nicely and a little touch of
olive oil
now linguine in first that's gonna take
the longest
eight to ten minutes
in
as linguine starts softening at the
bottom just gently turn that around
always wait the linguine is nice and
soft that way you don't break those nice
strands
give that a good mix get your lid back
on
[Music]
and bring that to the ball rapidly
after eight to ten minutes my linguini
should be perfect
you want it al dente slightly firm
not too chewy
absolutely spot-on
drain that
into a colander
shake a little bit of water from the
pasta into my sauce
and she goes
start twisting the linguine
round i want that bloody mary spicing up
the linguine
always hold up the center of the pan
first and place it onto the plate
let go of that nice big lump
by doing this you'll get a mountainous
pile of spaghetti with more body
then generously cover that with your
crispy breadcrumbs absolutely beautiful
last but not least i need to cook my
chilled herb buttered lobsters on a
smoking hot griddle
that butter's gotten really nice and
firm so the idea is
snapping that down
and grilling
the smell of that chili and garlic
butter is extraordinary
because the lobster's cooked all you're
doing is grilling that delicious spicy
chili butter you just want that mark of
the char quickly on the lobster
turn that over smell is incredible
[Music]
now get that on
[Music]
you can understand why it is proper
special occasion food because
that is mind-blowing
[Music]
griddled lobster with chili and garlic
butter serves with a boozy bloody merry
linguine a sensational special occasion
lunch
[Music]
in my restaurants the kitchens are
divided into different sections there's
a section that cooks fish and fish only
another for the meat and so on
the chef's become so good because
they're constantly improving all the
time practice makes perfect so if you
get a chance give my ultimate special
occasion dinner a trial run before you
cook it on your big night
on the menu is a succulent rare beef
fillet with salsa velvee
served with roasted truffle new potatoes
this is designed to make your special
occasion one to remember
and to end our ramsay get together with
a bang i've enlisted willing sous chef
jack
to help me make a sublime chocolate and
pistachio semi-freddo
i know you love chocolate right
we'll break this up so it melts nice and
evenly all right that goes over a memory
and you can't put the chocolate in
direct contact with the gas yeah okay
otherwise it will split crack four eggs
in every blue one of course hold on like
that
on the side and then your fingers in
and pull out okay good
nice
now you're cracking eggs with one hand
nice one i need some mussels okay start
whisking and i'll fold in a bit of
sugar come on let's do 30 seconds each
ready okay
come on jack give it some 13 year old
welly come on some muscles
10 seconds to go nine eight
seven six
five
four
three
two
one all right here we go your turn with
sugar let's go
you see the secret the whisking
vigorously is changing hands every ten
seconds yep now i'm gonna stir the
chocolate i'll stir that
now the secret behind this is getting it
really nice and thick and that's like a
stabbing on okay your turn come on
change change again yeah of course also
the chocolate leave that to slightly
cool down a touch
from there
cream in
why putting the cream in separately
because i'm gonna get it nice and thick
first if you start whisking that i'm
gonna get in the vanilla
to maximize the flavor from a vanilla
bean cut the pot in half lengthways and
scrape out those wonderfully aromatic
seeds
for extra flavor put the pod in as well
but remember to take it out once it's
infused
so we've got three components the melted
chocolate yes sugar yes and the eggs
whipped up
and the cream with the vanilla
next mix in your melted chocolate with
the sugar and egg sauvignon so you got a
nice
rich
chocolate ganache smell how delicious
i'm now i'm putting the cream and so you
just
whisk that in
now look at that how gorgeous is that
looking
and that my son
is a chocolate semifreddo
now they taste
[Music]
pistachio sachets right sprinkle them in
now get your bacon tray you line that
with cling film so it's easy to pull out
once it sets and then you just pour that
in
that is a real treat
so you fold that over okay is this like
ice cream in any way yeah as it sets
you slice it it's like this nice
chocolate ice block delicious
then put your semi-freddo into the
freezer for around three hours to set
right jack get that pan nice and hot
recognize that fillet of beef this is a
rolls-royce cup of beef so we've got to
treat it with some respect okay yeah mop
up all that seasoning
yeah
into the pan
and get that really nice and hot hello
teal
kiss mmm kiss
[Music]
a little bit of garlic and thyme in
there
cooking with these aromatic herbs and
garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a fillet of beef there's
hardly any fat on there so you sear it
quickly
ends as well gets seared i'm gonna now
put some butter in there
continue frying all those herbs
now
baste that with the butter
see
lana we're just having this are we gonna
have something with it now we're gonna
serve some beautiful baked potatoes with
truffle and a salsa verde into the oven
eight to ten minutes that's all
[Music]
next my super special bake new potatoes
wash and drain small new potatoes and
tip into a baking tray
drizzle with olive oil then season with
a touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper
place into an oven preheated at 180
degrees celsius and bake for 35 minutes
until crisp on the outside and soft all
the way through
transfer to your serving dish and grate
over fresh parmesan cheese
last but not least shave gorgeous earthy
black truffle slivers onto the cheesy
potatoes
bake new potatoes with a lavish twist
indulgent but couldn't be simpler to
make
right sounds a birthday
anchovies little touch of anchovy oil in
there okay we have anchovies after that
we've got some capers
garlic
in with the anchovies and the capers
okay a touch
of salt one only a touch because you
call the salt from the actually that's
right well then dijon mustard
sugar vinegar give that a nice mix
now this is where it starts to go to a
completely different level some fresh
mint and some fresh parsley i want half
of it in there
pureed
a touch of olive oil in there in
the rest of the mint
a touch of salt
pepper
excited yeah
you know taste
i'd love some of these
what's it taste like
fat
might need to try a tiny bit more
just to check
stop
you can't kiss any boys now
before the kids polish off all the
sounds of elderly i need a distraction
and i think my b phillip will do the job
nicely
look at this baby hot holes
up
look at that
seared and look how juicy
and tender that is take that out and let
that sit
on there
a little spoon just while it sits and
rests obviously building
as the beef cools down that south of the
other marinades
that
goes to the table very carefully please
tails take it over the baked potatoes
please all right send me photo
now
look at that nice
[Applause]
wow and then you just get the chocolate
and you grate it
over
[Music]
she's gorgeous
how delicious is that let's get one do
not drop that please okay i'm going up
to my bedroom now jack
this is my ultimate special occasion
dinner
the tenderest rare beef fillet with
punchy salsa velde
served with extravagant truffled new
potatoes
and a sublime chocolate pistachio
semifredo
it's always a special occasion in our
house when my wonderful mum and her
husband jimmy turn up for dinner sit
down guys please
[Music]
this is a definite special occasion
cheers nan
nice to see you
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you